it's hard to believe that only a week
ago luna was one of the top
cryptocurrencies with billions of
dollars flowing into it and all it took
was one market downturn to turn this
golden token into digital toilet paper i
mean in one week luna has gone from 80 a
token to less than one this chart is
just hard to look at i'm warning you it
reminds me of bitconnect not to mention
ust their stablecoin is still d-pegged
and at this point i think it's safe to
say it's over for terraform labs there's
simply no way to re-establish the trust
that algorithmic stablecoins need i mean
after all who wants an unstable
stablecoin so today we're going to try
to explain what happened and tell the
story of why i think this collapse was
predictable by that i mean it was
literally predicted there was a 20
million dollar bet about this and i'm
also going to be honest with you about
what we don't know as well because
before we move further let me say loud
and clear as of right now
no one knows the true culprit for this
crash so far i've counted four different
and unique threads going viral all
claiming to know how luna collapsed and
the explanation is slightly different
each time but what is consistent is
their proof is trust me bro in fact my
personal favorite of these explanations
is the theory that citadel who's the
gamestop super villain secretly gotten a
hundred thousand bitcoin loan from
gemini which is owned by the winkle
twins and they destroyed luna with it
now jim and i denied these claims but
who are you gonna believe a private
company or an anonymous 4chan post kind
of a toss-up right and i'm not even
saying these are wrong they just don't
have any evidence so that's where it
stands with this forensic side of things
a lot of people claim to have solved it
but nobody seems to actually have done
so but while we don't know exactly what
happened i think it's important to say
this crash also didn't surprise anyone
and i think that's worth talking about
there were a lot of people who have been
calling for this for some time and these
were mostly for two reasons which we've
already discussed ust was built on a
ponzi scheme and algo's stable coins
have sort of always failed and we've
covered those but there's a third option
that i really think has been overlooked
in all this and that is dokwan's role
remember that dokuan is the creator of
terraform lapse and what most people
don't know is that as luna became more
and more successful do kwan slowly
became more and more arrogant he would
dismiss all his critics and call them
poor and i believe this played a role at
least in so many people rooting for
luna's downfall if not actively playing
a role in it as i said we don't know if
luna's demise was like an attack or
naturally occurring but i want to give
you some examples of this because i
think we can learn from it about sort of
what not to do if you suddenly happen to
become ultra rich and powerful so on
november 25th 2021 a guy named freddy
reynolds proposed a theory of how you
could crash luna with a soro-style black
wednesday attack by that he's referring
to when george soros broke the british
pound and he goes into great detail
about how you could do this if you just
had a billion dollars on hand he
described a process where you could make
50 million dollars and sort of rinse and
repeat it until luna falls apart now in
response to this possible attack vector
does luna investigate does it implement
strategies to defend itself
no instead dokwan says this probably the
most thread i've read this decade
silence is a perfectly acceptable option
if stupid and then basically he asks
sort of to be attacked he says
billionaires in my following go ahead
see what happens i mean can you imagine
the arrogance to taunt billionaires that
are following you and going like yeah
see what happens go ahead attack me see
what happens now look
i know the internet's kind of a wild
place but i usually think there are two
rules to it that you have to abide by at
all times
one
don't ever taunt the internet and two
don't ever taunt billionaires and you
certainly don't want to do both at the
same time but this kind of arrogant
response wasn't even an irregular
occurrence rather than engaging with
flaws in his protocol dokuan would
repeatedly call his critics poor in fact
a few days before luna collapsed do kwan
said that if you listen to crypto
influencers about ustd pegging for the
69th time or you could remember that
they're all poor now and go for a run
instead and he repeatedly did this he
also taunted this guy al god trading who
said if luna breaks new all-time highs i
will short it with size
and do kwan responds yeah but your size
is not size this guy responds
statistically you're dunking on 99 of
your community but all right someday
your ponzi will collapse you can't keep
fueling anchor and this is my favorite
part of the story because that same guy
then responds four days later offering a
one million dollar bet that luna will be
at a lower price in exactly one year now
what does dokwan do he takes it of
course he takes the bait he says cool
i'm in and i guess that got enough
attention because someone noticed it and
decided that they actually wanted to
raise the stakes gcr on twitter decides
to offer a 10 million dollar bet dokwan
once again agrees and they decide on the
escrow being another crypto twitter user
kobe and so right now at this address
which we will put on screen there's
currently a 10 million dollar bet going
on on the blockchain this is real money
we're talking about um literally just
put up to see if
luna's gonna fall or not which obviously
uh two months later it did but even that
wasn't enough for gcr who at the time
decides he wants to double the bet
saying the initial spirit of it was this
like yeah your size is not size whatever
like kind of a weird insult weird way to
say you're poor basically um and so he
says look we're gonna play for big money
i'll double it to 20 million dollars to
which dokuan doesn't respond and so
instead what this guy does is he decides
he's going to short luna with the
remaining 10 million dollars that he
wanted to bet him with now for those of
you following along at home this is what
we call a chad move this guy would end
up cashing out with 16 to 20 million
dollars profit and it shows how much
dokuan pissed everyone off not just the
quote poor people but actually the
richest part of crypto twitter remember
he literally asked billionaires to
attack his protocol and to make it even
worse he also began attacking other
competitors around this time
saying about stable coins like die by my
hand die will die and it was sort of
this unique combination of arrogance
antagonism and disregard for criticism
that contributed either directly or
indirectly to luna's collapse people
don't like a sore winner and it's fair
to say that do kwan had to learn that
lesson the hard way my point was sharing
this isn't to suggest that the only
reason luna collapsed is because this
guy is kind of a jerk because remember
they were basically running a ponzi
scheme but being a jerk
along with sort of running uh and
benefiting from a ponzi scheme
definitely doesn't help and the other
bit of news we learned in all of this is
that coindesk reported that do kwan was
secretly behind a failed stable coin in
the past called basis cash he turned out
to be anonymously involved going by the
pseudonym rick and his partner was
called morty according to coindesk he
modeled the project after an earlier
project called basis which you may or
may not remember as the failed project
of founder nader al-najji the creator of
bitcloud so that's where we are with
this story a lot has come out and while
i hold very little sympathy for dokwan's
failure i do feel bad for all the
traitors who got swept up in it for
example ksi claimed to have bought a
hundred thousand luna claiming it could
be the quote best or worst trade of my
life he later says he spent 2.8 million
dollars buying the dip and that is luna
was now worth a thousand dollars ouch
and that's not even to mention the
regular investors who don't have
millions to spare i mean i cannot stress
this enough billions of dollars have
been wiped out overnight like reddit
communities are being makeshifted from
supporters into support groups like i
don't want to show you guys too much of
this because it is dark some investors
lost houses others lost life savings and
that's truly sad but we can't forget
about the painful lessons things like
luna can teach us in this case it's sort
of three things don't taunt internet
billionaires don't build ponzi schemes
and beware algo's stablecoins that's
basically it pump the stock and i'll see
you in the next one